now medical workers in Hong Kong are
protesting against what they say is
police brutality months of
anti-government protests have often
ended in bloodshed police have fired
tear gas and rubber bullets at
protesters with medics sometimes caught
in the middle difficult Parlin has the
latest from the protest in the city's
financial center among these crowds are
doctors nurses paramedics and other
medical professionals they say they have
several concerns and one of them is that
they're now being asked to disclose to
the police which of their patients were
involved in the protest movement the
other main concern is what they're
calling the excessive use of force by
the police against protesters I'm a
radiographer in Hong Kong for a hospital
so we have treated quite a lot of the
citizen that has been arrested by the
police
after some types of protests and we saw
that a lot of these patients has been
assaulted by the police Hong Kong
protesters have five key demands one of
them was met earlier this week when the
Hong Kong government formally withdrew a
proposed extradition law that law could
have seen Hong Kong criminal suspects
being sent to mainland China to face
this judicial system they're their other
main demands is an independent inquiry
into what CNF excessive force used by
the police but Hong Kong's chief
executive has rejected this saying that
one of her concerns is the reaction of
Hong Kong's 30,000 strong police force
they say they themselves are victims of
violence they accuse protesters among
other things of throwing rocks and
petrol bombs at police stations and at
the police all of the guys have injured
but the police use an equal force to the
post caster police have used water
cannons tear gas rubber bullets and the
even live rounds against protesters not
long ago Hong Kong's police were finally
regarded and highly respected they were
seen as one of them
professional institutions in the city
but over the past five months of
protests that reputation has
deteriorated dramatically